ten-year-old boy is dead tonight after
police say he was shot by his 14 year
old brother it happened this morning in
a neighborhood near horizon ridge in
gibson in henderson sasha loftis spoke
with those who live in the area and
joins us now live from the clark county
juvenile hall with the latest sasha
denise that boy's brother is here at
juvenile hall tonight we spoke with some
people who lived down the street from
where this happened they say this entire
situation has really rocked their
henderson neighborhood
a devastating situation leaves this
henderson neighborhood completely shaken
it's crazy i mean it's just you just
don't expect it to happen in your
neighborhood police say a ten-year-old
boy was shot and killed wednesday his
14-year-old brother is facing an
involuntary manslaughter charge
connected to his death those who live
nearby say they can't believe something
like this could happen me and my whole
family were super
super surprised and shocked and saddened
by it too rebecca joachim says as a
fellow parent her heart goes out to the
family involved if that ever happened to
me i don't know what i would do neither
she nor fellow neighbor donald housley
knew the children involved or their
parents
but he says this area is normally quiet
and safe which makes this even more
upsetting it's very unusual to hear that
it happens right around the corner from
your house because we've never been this
close to something like this happening
and they hope they never see anything
like this happen here ever again that's
extremely devastating i can't even
imagine what they're going through